one of the big misconceptions of leaders  is that they think that they need to  tell other people what to do in my  humble opinion this is often a mistake  if you do this you train your employees  to not think for themselves you train  them that they might not even be  responsible to come up with the good  Solutions themselves instead make sure  that you very clearly explain the goal  that you want to achieve explain the why  the vision for that and the rather ask  your team to come up with options for  Solutions of course you would then give  feedback provide guidance try to help  them as good as possible but coming up  with the plan this often should be done  by your team follow from your careers